it has been easier for me to change my
conditions than to change who I am and
so I have used my material success and
accolades to quiet the voices of not
being good enough if I had that little
voice that peeps up it's like hey look
at that I'm not that bad what is the
thing you're afraid of inside of
yourself if not as good as I think maybe
everything that I've been putting on
media maybe my book maybe all these
things are actually not true and I don't
know what I'm talking about there's a
zillion people who are like you suck
none of this is true whatever and for me
it rolls off my back because I have
evidence right it is true and here's how